2023 Wellness influencers
really are the gifts that
just keep on giving hey everyone
I'm Abby sharp welcome to aby's
Kitchen today we're going to be taking a look
at the Highlight Reel of the most unhinged
problematic Wellness influencer advice and
let me tell you this year did not disappoint
and by not I mean it has been a dumpster fire of
disappointment before we dive in I want to give
a shout out to today's sponsor my Heritage so my
mom and I have always been really interested in
our family's history so before my grandfather
died he recorded a bunch of tapes documenting
his whole life and they are so fascinating to say
the least so I've always been eager to learn more
about who and where I came from and my Heritage
makes it so easy to build your family tree this
is the leading global service for family history
research and DNA testing they have 90 million
users and 19 billion easily searchable historical
records plus Advanced AI technology for repairing
and enhancing historical photos it's honestly
crazy I've been slowly working on the street bit
by bit and my plan is to share my findings with
my parents for the holidays along with their own
accounts so they can learn more about their own
ancestors but it's really an amazing service so
you basically plug in as many family members as
you can can and then you can research each one
for old records related to marriage licenses death
certificates newspaper clippings Maps schools and
more one thing I learned is that basically every
man on my mother's side is named Alan uh which I
guess is a tradition that my sister and I kind
of put to bed but even if you don't have a ton
of information they make it super easy to build
your tree with their instant discoveries function
and they can take old photos and basically bring
them to life it's super crazy but if you want to
start to build your family tree and research your
family history you can check out my link in the
description to get a free 14-day trial of the
my Heritage complete plan to get started today
well let's start with this misinformed video from
Autumn baits claiming that the protein and peanut
butter doesn't count 2 tablespoons of peanut
butter has 7 g of protein one egg has 6 g of
protein but the protein you get from peanut butter
doesn't really count it has a digestibility score
of 46 eggs have a score of 1.1 three this measures
how much protein you're actually absorbing so when
you eat one egg you get that full 6 g of protein
but when you eat two tablespoons of peanut butter
you're really only maybe getting 3 G all righty
now nutritionist Autumn and I may not share the
same approach to nutrition but I think most
of her content is generally scientifically
sound but I feel like she really misunderstood
the assignment here so Autumn's talking about
the D score which is the best method that we
have to assess ESS protein quality a score of
46 means that if you were to eat the average
requirement of protein from only peanut butter
only about 46% would be usable by the body this
is based on the fact that plant-based foods are
missing or low in one or more amino acids all of
which you need to synthesize protein tissue so
peanut butter is limited by methionine so if you
were to only consume peanut butter then of the 7
G per serving only around 3 G would be UTI I for
tissue synthesis but who the is only eating peanut
butter for their daily protein oh Ethan if we were
to Simply pair the peanut butter with like a slice
of bread which has plenty of methionine you've
got all the essential amino acids to utilize
the protein in that peanut butter Bread's limiting
amino acid is lysine but peanut butter has plenty
of that so it's like having two pieces of paper
with a few holes in each when you layer in a
variety of plant-based Foods you fill in all
the holes and you get more available protein
and by the way you don't need to consume these
complimentary proteins at the exact same time
either that protein combining theory has long
being debunked so this is actually a complete
nonissue for folks eating a normal non-restrictive
diet so if you like peanut butter enjoy it as one
of many sources of protein in your day just
because it's not the best source doesn't mean
that it doesn't count next let's take a look
at this advice from frugivore page Shay this
is the number one rule of food combining don't
eat protein and fat with fruit it's best to eat
fruit by itself or alongside vegetables and leafy
greens fruit digests very easily and quickly so
if you eat fruit along with a high protein high
fat meal all of the fat and protein is going to
get in fruit's way and it's going to cause gas
and discomfort oh gosh honestly of all the The
Fringe diets out there I have to say that the
whole high carb fravor food combining diet is
probably the one that makes the least amount
of scientific sense you just don't get it do
you so the suggestion that combining fruit
with anything that has protein or fat will
create some kind of like traffic jam in your gut
is so far from what the science tells us for one
our body is pretty sophisticated it's not like a
one lane Highway we can digest different foods at
different rates because our body releases the
right cocktail of digestive enzymes based on
what we put into our gut second digesting food
really fast isn't really a good thing like we
don't want fruit to just go right through us as
it would if you were to eat an entire watermelon
or banana smoothie in one go because if it does
our blood sugar would spike crash and we will
be hungry really soon after despite eating an
entire watermelon protein fiber and fat AKA my
Hunger crushing compounds will help to slow down
the blood sugar response which is one of the only
food combination strategies we want to follow
I mean this is the same Creator who insists
on keeping fat intake under 10% of calories and
that she got toned when she eliminated all major
protein sources so yeah I think it's safe to take
a hard pass on this advice all right moving on to
some of the worst Wellness influencer offenders
online Bobby Parish of Flav City I know there's
a nationwide shortage of formula still but have
you seen the ingredients in most they're not the
best the good news is there are some better
ones but take for example something like this
the first ingredient is non-fat milk that milk is
not organic that milk is not non GMO meaning the
milk is GMO it comes from cows that eat GMO grain
I would never eat GMOs I wouldn't want infants
doing that either strike number one how about
something like this see the sweetener in here
it's corn syrup salads why would they put corn
syrup in an infant formula cuz they're trying
to mimic the sweetness of breast milk mother's
milk well that sweetness is lactose this is the
opposite of that GMO corn syrup which is addictive
and lights up your brain in the way of a drug
to give this to an infant pretty pretty bad but
Bobby I buy organic formula well that's good cuz
like it says it's organic so it's non GMO milk
but look at the oils used in here organic palm
oil soybean oil sunflower safflower oil they're
trying to mimic the fat content of mother's milk
but these even though they're organic are highly
processed highly inflammatory High refined and
those kind of oils are also bad for the gut a
baby has the most gut microbiome they're ever
going to have at that age to start destroying
it with those ingredients is bad news but what's
the good news there are way better ones that are
not perfect but way better try getting something
called Serenity kids made with 100% grass-fed
milk how about organic lauca or organic hip from
Europe those are way better than these options
just keep in mind what you're putting in your
infant at this age is very important this is quite
possibly one of the most problematic insensitive
and toned deaf Bobby videos he is at put up oh
brother this guy stinks and based on his content
repertoire that's saying a lot so first of all
is Bobby a pediatrician a pediatric dietician
even a person who has attempted to feed another
human after pushing them out of his body because
as far as I'm concerned anyone can stand in a
grocery store and yell about ingredients to a
camera but it gives them zero Authority to speak
on a critical topic like infant nutrition at the
time this video was posted we were in the midst
of a serious infant formula shortage so honestly
read the room Bobby let's go through some of his
ill-informed grievances shall we first of all
GMOs not a concern for me GMOs have undergone
more detailed evaluation than any other group
of food products that we consume and the data
overwhelmingly indicates that the consumption
of GMOs pose zero risk to human health as for
corn syrup solids buddy Bobby next time just like
do a basic Google search before you get on the
horn but basically Bobby makes a stink about the
corn syrup solids being high fructus corn syrup
and that high fructus corn syrup is addictive
or toxic or whatever lots to say here keeping it
succinct first of all the claims that high fructus
corn syrup is addictive is based on rat data not
humans but this is a moot point more importantly
corn syrup solids aren't High fructus corn syrup
at all high fructus corn syrup has 55% fructose
to glucose ratio whereas core and syrup solids are
straight of glucose Bobby also says something to
the fact that lactose is the opposite of glucose
which again points to how little about nutrition
he actually knows lactose is a disaccharide made
up of glucose and galactose but because it was
meant for pries who often lack sufficient lactase
enzymes levels they mix it with glucose to make it
easier for them to digest not all formulas have
corn syrup solids but this has a very specific
clinical purpose to help babies Thrive Bobby then
rounds out his video with his usual vegetable oil
rant and we've cleared this up at nauseum over
here at aby's kitchen but to summarize while some
Studies have pointed to the potential inflammatory
properties of getting too much omega-6 in the diet
the larger body of high quality evidence suggests
that Omega 6 fats do not have a significant effect
on inflammation in fact a 2012 systematic review
assessed the effects of omega-6 linolic acids on
inflammatory markers and found no strong link
to suggest that they increased inflammation as
for the Bobby approved formula recommendations
this one is a toddler formula which is used when
most infants can actually literally come off
formula so unhelpful suggestion and both the
LCA and the hip contain vegetable oil as a third
ingredient which was one of the main things he
just ripped into so these may have other unique
features that make them the right choice for some
families but they're significantly more expensive
and way less accessible than drugstore Brands the
last thing that parents need is to be mansplained
misinformation when they are literally just trying
to do the best damn job that they can I am trying
really hard to keep it kind here because watching
Bobby's content makes me ragy AF you wouldn't
like me when I'm angry but let's move on to this
gut health tip from Liz cyber they say that the
gut is like the second brain once I learned how
to eat in a way that was gut healing my mental
health completely transformed today I'm going
to show you how to make one of my favorite easy
gut healing breakfast and it's going to keep you
full for hours starting with a lot of high quality
butter that I get from a farm we're going to add
carrots onions broccoli a clove of garlic then
we're just going to stir fry this in the butter
the reason that we're using these vegetables
is because they're very low carb and they're
not starchy starch is one of the things that can
really irritate the gut okay I'm going to stop
the video right here because basically the rest
is just some scrambled eggs with lots of butter
avocado and veg and it does look delicious but I
Flav this video because of the clear and misguided
message that carbs and starch irritate the gut
now IBS symptoms are very tricky obvious viously
everyone's experience of what triggers a flare
will be unique but generally speaking we know
that starchy foods are actually hugely beneficial
to the gut if we look at a type of starch in foods
like unripe bananas potatoes oats rice plantains
and legumes called resistant starch we see that
these actually act as unique Prebiotic fibers
to improve gut health microbiome diversity short
chain fatty acid production and immune response
the reason why people like Liz who have taken
on a super strict carnivore style diet may see
a reduction in GI symptoms is that they end up
cutting out a ton of potentially triggering foods
but elimination diets like the controversial gaps
diet that she references in this video or other
bogus gut healing diets that we hear about online
are not meant to be followed long term you're
supposed to eliminate then reintroduce most of
these foods that you cut out in a stepwise
manner so as Not to cause long-term harm to
microbiome and unfortunately this is a cycle
that we see in a lot of folks with histories
of disordered eating and eating disorders which
Liz has been very open about struggling with in
the past so I talked about this in more detail
in my video right here but often Enos orders can
cause functional gut disorders food sensitivities
and motility issues which then can lead people
towards hyper restrictive diets to try to get some
digestive relief which in the end can actually do
more long long-term damage in fact in the case of
the carnivore diet one review of the literature
found that people whose diet was low in fiber and
high in animal protein had microbiome disbiosis
and a specific bacterial ratio in the gut that
is associated with IBD so while the carnivore
diet with low amounts of beneficial starch or
Fiber May temporarily suppress some GI symptoms
It ultimately is not good for the gut and speaking
of carnivores we have got to talk talk about this
Gem of misinformation from the carnivore MD Paul
saladino I have elevated cholesterol but I don't
need a stab here's why in many people like myself
we eat a significant amount of saturated fat from
animal meat and avoid seed oils LDL cholesterol
Rises if I went to a classically trained doctor
they would beg me to take a stattin but my
elevated cholesterol does not mean that I am
at an increased risk of cardiovascular disease so
much dangerous misinformation in one short clip
so for one anytime I see an influencer pill
shame or discourage the public from taking a
life saving medication or seeking the advice of
classically trained doctors my eyes get a little
Twitchy look at my eye twitching I also find it
super convenient that Paul never shares references
or receipts for the studies he references so I
guess I'm going to be picking up the slack we
have and Le research that high LDL cholesterol
can increase the risk of heart disease because
that cholesterol can bury itself in the arterial
walls cause inflammation and increase your risk
of a heart attack or stroke now I assume his
argument is based on the heavily criticized
review that concluded that 92% of seniors with
high cholesterol ended up living longer suggesting
that the benefits of a Statin treatment had been
exaggerated But Not only was the study criticized
for bias and poor methods but 2third of its
participant pool came from just one study and
even that study found that Statin use provided a
survival benefit also being metabolically healthy
AKA maintaining low insulin levels doesn't erase
the damage that LDL can do to one's arteries nor
does it mean that he wouldn't benefit from
a Statin one 20year study of men with no
heart disease risk factors other than high LDL
cholesterol and no evidence of heart disease
found that just 40 Mig of a weak Statin reduced
coronary deaths by 28% honestly I don't really
give a what Paul does but I do care what kind of
BS he is spewing to the masses bullsh and finally
let's finish off with Coach Jeremy who apparently
had his Halloween doctor costume do double duty
this year with this notoriously misinformed video
yo are you serious right now do you realize that
doctors are literally poisoning young children
in this country when you turn back and you see
the label not only does it have sucrose which
is an artificial sweetener that disturbs the
brain but we have red 40 which has been proven to
cause hyperactivity in the brain and then guess
what that same doctor wants to prescribe your
young child with a methamphetamine like adero
whoa whoa whoa that escalated from like red 40
is dangerous to fullblown conspiracy theory that
doctors are giving their patients ADHD to make
money off of prescriptions honestly this makes
me sick I don't know if this guy has ever met a
child who has been sick but if your kid is a very
high fever and is like puking having diarrhea and
not wanting to eat or drink anything you are head
to the ER you don't give a about a little suc
Lo or red 40 you want your child to get better
and rehydrate because dehydration is a major
cause of morbidity and mortality in infants
and young children children worldwide largely from
acute viruses that cause diarrhea but to just set
the record straight on a few things sucrose AKA
Splenda is considered safe in moderate amounts
with human research showing no negative impact
on gut health and while I wouldn't personally
recommend children consume artificial sweeteners
like sucrose daily a little bit of sweetener to
encourage kids to drink an electrolyte supplement
that could very well save a life is absolutely
not a concern as for food d red 40 was actually
phased in as like a safer alternative to red 3
because red 3 was linked to thyroid cancer in rats
as for hyperactivity a 2004 analysis of 15 studies
did find that artificial food dyes like red 40
did slightly increase hyperactivity in children
while other research suggests that this effect
is genetically determined and not all children
react the same another meta analysis found an
association though not necessarily A causal
between food dyes and autism so even though this
is all quite inconclusive and correlation is not
causation I do think that there's reason to be
cautious with overc consumption that said if your
kid is exhausted from dehydration the benefits of
a rehydration solution far at weigh any potential
small boost in hyperactivity and if your child
is sensitive there are unsweetened and die free
options as a mom I'll be honest I do try to avoid
food dyes under normal everyday circumstances but
I can't really imagine my kids wanting to drink
salty clear liquid when they don't want to eat or
drink anything at all so I will take a life-saving
sweetened dyed substance on occasion over my kidne
to go to the ER to be put on a drip but you know
what we are lucky to have options here and when
Jeremy has kids and his kids are violently
ill he can do that risk benefit analysis for
himself well folks there's no shortage of
crazy unhinged Wellness advice making its
rounds and you know I will always be here taking
it down as it comes our way so don't forget to
hit that subscribe button for more diet culture
BS take down content like this video check out
my description for my free Hunger crushing combo
ebook and I'll see you next time on aby's kitchen
cheers